if an LLC owns the rental house the
tenant gets drunk and falls off the
porch and decides it's your fault and
sues you they have to sue the owner of
the house which is the LLC exactly okay
and if they were to win they can take
what that LLC owns but nothing else so
your other assets like your personal
residence are then protected so by
putting your properties up to a certain
point in an LLC and then it if once the
Target on the LLC gets too big you do
another LLC so I've got a bunch of them
um like I've got one building that's a
$15 million office building it's its own
LLC okay you see what I'm doing but if
somebody Falls over there the worst case
scenario if they get past the insurance
they get past me pipe paying lawyers to
sue them for being stupid and so on the
most they're going to get is that
building